Diane Keaton says it's been over three
decades since she's gone on a date are
you kidding me
the 73 year old Oscar winner covers the
August issue of InStyle subscriber
issues and gets candid about her dating
life quote I haven't been on a date in I
would say 35 years no dates I have a lot
of male friends I have a lot of friends
but no dates
Diane has had some high-profile
relationships in the past among her
boyfriends Woody Allen Warren Beatty and
Al Pacino he didn't even care for me
very much I bet he did
but alright he was sexy during a stop by
Ellen in 2018 Dianne admitted that she
still thinks her ex is the sexiest man
alive well once upon a time you know
when I was younger I had boyfriends and
I liked them a lot you know and one of
them I think is the sexiest man alive I
still think that to this day maybe you
guys don't agree I know it for me Al
Pacino ah and she revealed her current
celebrity crush Chris Martin oh okay
when she was asked about her sex life
you're not supposed to say things like
that on TV are you Diane
dropped this gem yeah well I would say I
don't have one
yeah you know like it's gone gone I
don't I don't participate in that okay
sometimes you know Annika